imagine your team's star player is
sidelined days before the biggest
tournament in your game's history
sure the roster has a solid backbone and
there are other players who can pop off
but it's hard to imagine them going the
distance without that added star power
but on this rare occasion the right
player stepped into that void
and even without much practice
absolutely destroyed the competition
hell if what we saw from sentinels this
past weekend was any indication
they might look even better with the
replacement
that's why we have to talk about tens
hey guys if you're watching this video
it's probably not the first time we've
talked to you about subbing to our
channel
but maybe it's the time you should
actually do it we're on the road to 2
million subs and we need your help to
get there
so why don't you hit that subscribe
button ring the notification bell
and let us know in the comments below
what kind of stories you're keeping an
eye on
maybe we could talk about them in a
future don't at me okay so
if you're not familiar with tens here's
a quick refresher he played cs go
and eventually earned his big shot with
cloud 9
in that game but after only a few months
on the roster he was benched but make no
mistake
he had a rep as an aim god a phenom
after becoming the organization's first
valorem player tens showed off some
crazy skills with cloud9 blue
and for a lot of people it was further
evidence that he was one of the best
young aimers in valorante
but that team didn't dominate the
limited slate of events available during
the ignition series era
and it mostly became known for his
strong play
sometimes sardonically labeled tens and
friends
whether you agree with that moniker or
not tens was clearly an important part
of this roster
so when he later announced a swap to
streaming and content creation
still under contract with cloud9 of
course it felt like his developing
potential was being wasted
but why is tens playing for sentinels
now
on march 9th sentinel star player jay
sinatra wan
was accused of sexual assault by his
ex-girlfriend
cleo we already did a video about the
situation so we won't go into detail
here
but the accusation less sinatra
suspended from the team
and unable to play in the upcoming
masters tournament
pending an investigation the suspension
announced a couple days before vct na
master stage one began
left sentinels with a decision who
replaces sinatra well we got an
answer pretty quick after riot granted
them an exception to fill out their
roster
sentinels were able to acquire tens from
cloud9
here's sentinel's igl shazam talking
about the move on stream
i jammed him on twitter player i said yo
you want to play
he said i'm down yeah so um i'm on i'm
on
loan from from c9 to sentinels so
basically
centals is just taking over my contract
and i'm fully representing samples
so the accusations against sinatra go
public on march
9th on march 10th he suspended from both
sentinels
and the vct and on march 11th sentinels
announced that they've acquired
tens and he's going to be playing with
them at masters which starts in less
than 24 hours
we're talking about a player who hadn't
played a competitive match in like
two months and then he's signed up as
the sub
for sentinels and he had basically no
time before
and to practice like he had basically
one
hour of practice in regards to practice
since it was such a last minute thing
of getting me um
we haven't practiced at all and tomorrow
is the tournament
and i don't think we have scrims before
the tournament so
tomorrow at 12 pst
it'll basically be our uh our scrim
right there
and keep in mind this is right before
the biggest tournament for n a
yet and sentinels were probably
considered favorites by many
at least top two by most there were
obviously still
questions about the roster even with
tens's firepower
how would he be able to fit into
sentinel system
who the hell would play jet would shazam
be able to figure out the best way for
all of this to work
and to that last question the answer was
a resounding
yes at the beginning of the year it was
in their ability to take specifically
against sentinels
but now that tens is in the fold i don't
know that you're gonna be
nearly as effective as you were before
the ace is stolen but it doesn't matter
sentinels hold fast against lg the team
found their footing with big
performances for both sick
and tense on map three tens was
absolutely
off the chain going 27 15 and 9
with a 275 average damage per round
and listen if you thought tens was done
with content creation for the moment
you're wrong because he gave us some
pretty good clips
he's got the frenzy and he's got it oh
man
all up and moves his face and he's
getting a jumping one as well on the
thief
i said this the first time i call tens
this is his world
and we're just living in it he's got
four he's going hunting for the ace
let him off the leash he's digging it it
was clear that tens had found his stride
by the end of this series
and it's kind of funny because he later
admitted that he played that first
map with a comically high sensitivity
but the real test would be hundred
thieves
later that weekend their slower one
duelist style would surely
contrast against the looser to duelist
style being played by sentinels
but even though map 2 went to overtime
it was
sentinels moving on to winners finals
3v3 he's got the showstopper as well
tents looking to go big for sentinels
and so far
so good this fight goes down number
advantage in favor of sentinels and
oh my gosh pens is just a man possessed
dapper does it as well and sentinel's
social media guy
gave us one of the best post series
clapbacks
ever this is honestly a series that
sentinels with their last minute
substitution
would have been forgiven for losing but
instead their opponents are giving them
props
unfortunately the same can't be said for
hundred thieves
so far they've struggled to dominate
with their slower one duelist style
in the adrenaline addicted and a
landscape
and listen maybe history will absolve
hundred thieves
for moving to this slower style and just
working through these growing pains
now maybe in two years we'll look back
nostalgically at this time and think
wow wasn't it awesome you could run two
duelists
wasn't it so cool that you could play
phoenix
do you remember how everyone was saying
schmieg nonstop
there's no that nobody else no other jet
schmiegs bro it's only me dog
i'm the only jet that actually schmidt's
don't confuse
playing good with schmiege for the
moment hundred thieves
have to just figure this thing out and
sentinels
have to keep up the pressure on their
opponents tens was an important part of
that pressure
but also key to these victories was sick
who played
incredibly well personally and in tandem
with tens
sentinel's in-game leader shazam has
also seemed to have an
easy time making tens comfortable he was
able to explain
most stuff that they would do and stuff
within like an hour and kind of slot me
into rule like
the role um and then he was able to kind
of like counter call against
um lg he was able to get some good reads
against honor thieves he was getting
some good reads
so shaz's igl ability is
the same future is still up in the air
but with tens on the roster this team is
demolishing some of the best teams in na
at least against lg and hundred thieves
this roster looks like it has the
potential to win it all
these guys are incredibly fun to watch
and if tens ends up going back to
content creation and streaming
after this is all done it'll be an
unfortunate loss for the community
it's worth pointing out that tens
confirmed on stream that he's on loan to
sentinels for at least the duration of
masters
i'm on loan from c9 to sentinels but
the way the loan is working is like send
i'm
fully under sentinels for the duration
listen tens is wasted on the ladder he
needs to be
on a top roster one that gives him the
support he needs in the server to win
matches and outside of game to continue
to develop his skills
if long term that roster ends up being
sentinels i think valorent fans could be
in for a hell of a ride
sentinels will face faze clan on friday
another awesome story there and one that
i'm excited to bring to you
later this week hopefully with some
comments by the shmig himself
what did you guys think of sentinel's
opening weekend with tens
let me know in the comments below
i feel like my own trajectory as a human
being has mirrored child of us
in the sense that like there was a time
when i was like a different person i'm
just like not that person anymore and i
feel like shia labeouf's the same way
now now having said that i think he's
well i'm not going to [ __ ] talk shia
labeouf he'll come to my house so i
don't i don't i don't want that but you
know
you're like hey you know what the
[ __ ] deal is put your coat up by the
[ __ ] door
you know exactly two kinds we got
domestic
we got premium we have domestic we have
domestic premium
we have that's it there's no stouts
a porter's a thing they got at the
hilton